اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى ساعه اخباريه جديده
نخصص معظمها لتغطيه المشهد السوداني
بدايتها كالعاده بالعنوي
الجيش السوداني يعلن استمرار التصدي
لتحركات الدعم السريعي وتهيئه عوده الشرطه
تدريجيا
قوات الدعم السريع تتهم طائرات الجيش
السوداني بانتهاك الهدنه والتعرض لها
بهجمات مدفعيه
نقابه الاطباء تعلن تعرض سته عشر مستشفى
للقصف منذ بدايه الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
متحدث الجيش الاوكراني يقول بان بلاده لا
تزال تحتفظ باحد طرق الامداد الهامه في
باخبوت
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله رغم الهدنه الانسانيه التي لا
تزال مستمره بين طرفي الصراع في السودان
الا ان الاشتباكات تجددت في ولايات
سودانيه فيما تبادل الجيش والدعم السريع
الاتهامات مجددا بشان انتهاك الهدنه
المعلنه ياتي ذلك فيما تتفاقم الاوضاع
الطبيه حيث دعا الهلال الاحمر المنظمات
الدوليه بتقديم مساعداتها العاجله لتجاوز
الازمه
هذا وفي التفاصيل ومع دخول المعارك بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع اسبوعها الثالث
وبعد ليله هادئه نسبيا شهدتها الخرطوم
تجددت الاشتباكات صباح اليوم حيث تشهد
منطقه المهندسين والصالحه اشتباكات
بالاسلحه الخفيفه واتقي له وقصفا بالطيران
حسب مراسل العربيه وبحسب شهود عيان من
منطقه الحلفاء الى شمال مدينه الخرطوم
بحري بدا الجيش في نشر وحداته والقيام
بعمليات تمشيط بعد معارك عنيفه شهدتها
المنطقه امس هذا وتجدد سماع دوي انفجارات
واصوات اطلاق النار في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش
الجيش
تنشيط وضخمه جدا
الان
وضخمه جدا
من الجيش
من جانبه اتهم الجيش السوداني استمرار
قوات الدعم السريع في انتهاك الهدنه
المعلنه من خلال عمليات تحشيد تقوم بها
غرب العاصمه الخرطوم الجيش دان استمرار
القصف العشوائي وعمليات نهب الممتلكات بما
فيها البنوك ومنازل المواطنين وقال بيان
للجيش ان قوات الدعم السريع حولت مستشفى
شرق النيل الى تكنه عسكريه ومركز قياده
لعملياتها البيان اكد على استمرار الجيش
في تهيئه الظروف المناسبه لنزول الشرطه
تدريجيا الى الشوارع
[موسيقى]
في المقابله تامه قواته الدعم السريع
الجيشة بمهاجمه مواقع تمركزها في عدد من
مناطق الخرطوم بالمدافع والطائرات بيان
الدعم السريع اشار الى ان طائرات الجيش ما
تزال تحلق في سماء الخرطوم وتنتهك الهدنه
الدعم السريع قال ان الجيش يستعد لشن هجوم
في العاصمه الخرطوم
والحلفايه وام درمان وبحري
هذا واظهرت صور متداوله اشتعال حريق في
بنك السوداني المركزي في وقت تعاني فيه
البلاد من حاله انفلات امنيه
السودان المركزي
الاخير
الله يسترنا طبعا بيننا مش عارف بس اي
حاجه
اقل من
يعني لو وقع الاخير في لبنان خلاص
الله يسهل
خبرتها عن التحيه لقوه التحيه للمشاهدين
الكرام هذه
الهدنه كانت بالفعل هو هشه لان
الاجتماع الحين لاخر يعني بالامس كان هناك
اشتباك في كوبري الحلفايه وكانت
هناك ذوي الانفجارات سمع في مدينه ام
درمان بكثافه
واليوم بيان الدعم السليم
مضطر لمقاطعتك فقط
لقراءه هذه الاخبار العاجله اسفل الشاشه
لمشاهدينا ومستمعينا ايضا كذلك الشرطه
السودانيه تقول بان مقر البنك المركزي
الرئيسي سليم والحريق المتداول لاحد فروعه
اذا الشرطه السودانيه الان تقول بان مقر
البنك المركزي
السوداني والتي انتشرت بعض الصور في مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وصور متداوله ايضا
لحريق شابه في احد الابنيه في العاصمه
الخرطوم
وتم تناقل خبر بانه طبعا البنك المركزي
الرئيسي لكن الان الجيش السوداني او عفوا
الشرطه السودانيه تقول بان مقر البنك
المركزي الرئيسي السوداني السليم لم يتعرض
الى اي تخريب او الى عمليه ايضا اشعال
النيران فيه
والحريقه المتداول كان لاحد فروعه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اذا هذا هو
البيان والتبيان من الشرطه السودانيه عن
هذا الفيديو المتداول والذي كنا قد عرضناه
ايضا قبل قليل اعود مره اخرى الى الخرطوم
الى سيده رشا عود رئيس التحرير صحيفه
التغيير كنت اسال عن الهدنه
ووصفها بان هدنه هشه هل يمكن البناء عليها
هل يمكن ايضا ان يكون هناك قواعد جديده
لاي هدنه مستقبلا في السودان او حتى بعد
انتهاء هذه الهدنه مباشره تفضلي
لحتى تكون هناك خذن حقيقيه
يستفيد منها المواطنون
الذين لا
يستطيعون حتى مغادره منازلهم لابد من
تركيبات
لمراقبه الهدنه ترتيبات مهنيه باشراف
الامم المتحده وجود رقابه
فنيه تستطيع ان تحدد من الذي ينتهك ومن
الذي يطلق النيران ويخترق الهدنه
الان يقولون ان هناك هد
تتجدد الاشتباكات يقع الضحايا
والطرفان يتبادلان الاتهامات تتحدثين عن
ضروره وجود مراقبين دوليين لهذه
الهدنه او الهدن المستقبليه ايضا
نعم كانت هناك طرف مستقل يحدد من هو
المسؤول عن خلق هذه الهدنه الان نحن نستمع
الى بيان الدعم السريع وهو
تهديد بانه هناك اشتراكات عنيفه في الطريق
وهذا امر مؤسف لان كثيرا من المواطنين ما
زالوا محاصرين في منازلهم الاشتباكات تدور
بعنف وباتلحه ثقيله
وهناك هلع وسط المواطنين عندما يستمعون
الى مثل هذه البيانات لان لاجها
تحرص على سلامه البدنيين او توفر لهم
ممرات امنه لمغادره
هذه المدينه يعني ما دام هناك تصميم على
تحويل الخرطوم الى ساحه حرب بهذا الشكل
فلابد ان تكون هناك تدابير
لعشرات الالاف من السكان الذين ما زالوا
في المنطقه الخطر طيب انت تتحدثين عن
ضروره وجود مراقبين دوليين لتنفيذ اي هدنه
مستقبليه لكن هذا الكلام ربما يتناقض
اليوم مع ما يحدث في السودان من الخروج
البعتات الدوليه الامميه الدبلوماسيه ايضا
وراعياهم مواطنين الدول الاجنبيه
فبالتالي ربما وجود مراقبين دوليين كما
يقول البعض بانه من الصعب ان يتم تنفيذه
الان في السودان خصوصا في العاصمه الخرطوم
كيف تعلقين
لحمايه المدنيين السودانيين انا ما يعنيني
في هذا الصراع باكمله هو حمايه المواطنين
السودانيين المدنيين وتقليل الكلفه
الانسانيه الى حدها الادنى ثم الدخول في
حال سياسي لهذه الازمه
[موسيقى]
عندما تلوح طوادر السياسي سوف تتصاعد
الاشتباكات ولا يتم الالتزام باي غدوه
معلن عنها لان كل طرف يريد ان يحقق تقدما
ميدانيا ليخدم ادندته على طاوله المفاوضات
وهذا ما يحدث الان كل طرف يرغب في تحقيق
مكاتب عسكريه المدنيون يدفعون الثمن هناك
مناطق القتال فيها محتدم اكثر من الخرطوم
مناطق متعدده من العالم
ووجدت القوات الدوليه طريقها الى الفصل
بين القوات المتحاربه
وضمان وقف اطلاق نار حقيقي
هل يعني احتدام الاشتباكات سيده رشا حسب
تقييمك يعني هل يعني بان الاطراف يعني
اصبحت قريبه من الجلوس على طاوله
المفاوضات من ان على الاقل المبعوثه
الاممي الخاص طبعا بالمين العامل المتحده
عندما
قال بان الاطراف السودانيه او بان الطرفي
هذه الازمه يعني قد اقترب من الجلوس على
طاوله التفاوض او الحوار احتدام
المعارك هذه الايام هل له اي علاقه بهذا
التصريح برايك
هو بالفعل حدث التغير في الموقف المتشدد
الذي استمعنا اليه في اليوم الاول لاندلاع
الحرب يعني كان الخطاب المتبادل بين قائد
الدعم السريع وقائد الجيش كان خطابا صفريا
واستئصاليا كل طرف يقول ان الحل هو
استسلام الطرف الاخر بالامس
الجيش عينه مبعوثه الخاص للحوار وكذلك
الدعم السريع عينه مضعوفا خاصا وهذا يدل
انه ان الطرفين عمليا قابله بمبدا الحل
التفاوضي هناك طرف ثالث يدخل على الخط
لانه لا يريد حل التفاوضيا يريد استمرار
الحرب واحراق البلاد هذا الطرف هو فضول
النظام البائد وهم الان يصدرون البيانات
المحرضه على استمرار القتال وان ليس هناك
افق سوى هذه المواجهات عسكريه ولكن
الحقائق الميدانيه على الارض حتى الان
والحرب دخلت اسبوعها الثالث تقول ان الحسم
العسكري لكل الطرفين تعذر تماما وانه ما
يتبادلان السيطره على المواقع هنا وهناك
وهناك حاله توازن وحاله الاشتباك
مزيد من
اشكرك جزيل الشكر من الخرطوم رئيس التحرير
صحيفه التغيير رشا عوض شكرا جزيلا لك اذكر
فقط بجمله الاخبار العاجله اسفل الشاشه
والتي ظهرت قبل قليل نقلا عن الخارجيه
السودانيه تقول بانها تطالب المجتمع
الدولي بادانه سلوك مجموعه الدعم السريع
وبانها تدين ايضا اعتداءات الدعم السريعه
على مقر البعثات والهيئات الدبلوماسيه
وقالت ايضا بان مقر البنك المركزي الرئيسي
سليم والحريق متداول لاحد فروعه هذا كان
طبعا على لسان الشرطه السودانيه لكن
الخارجيه السودانيه قالت بانها تدين
اعتداءات الدعم السريع على مقر البعثات
والهيئات الدبلوماسيه وتطالب المجتمع
الدولي بادانه سلوك مجموعات الدعم السريع
هذا ربما ابرز ما جاء في تصريحات الخارجيه
السودانيه ومعه ايضا تصريح الشرطه
السودانيه فيما يخص مقر البنك المركزي
السوداني اذا وفي ذات السياق حضر رئيس
الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد الله حمدوك
من في السودان قد يتفاقم الى احدى اسوا
الحروب الاهليه في العالم في حال لم يتم
وضع حد له واعتبر ان ذلك سيشكل كابوسا
للعالم وستكون له تداعيات كبيره وراى
حمدوك ان نزاع الحالي هو عباره عن حرب لا
معنى لها مؤكدا ان لا احد سيخرج منها
منتصرا
فالاثناء قال المتحدث الرسمي لقوى الحريه
والتغيير للعربيه ان القوى السياسيه
تتواصل مع اطراف دوليه واطراف عسكريه في
الداخل للتفاوض والوصول الى حل للازمه
لانه نحن على تواصل برضه مع مع اطراف
دوليه ومع بعض الاطراف من العسكريين في
الداخل
للنقاش معهم حول يعني ما يمكن ان يتم من
تساقط لانهاء هذه الازمه بالتالي هم ابدوا
الموافقه وهذا معلوم بالتالي نعتقد انه
الام ما يدور لطالما انه الطرفين وافقوا
على الحوار يبقى استمرار المعارك واضح انه
هو لتحسين الموقف على الارض
الخرطوم ينضموا الينا اللواء بدر الدين
حسن عبد الحكم الباحث في اكاديميه الامن
العليا للدراسات الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه مرحبا بك معي سعاده اللواء
على شاشه العربيه اريد ان تقيم لنا الوضع
الان
الامني الوضع العسكري ايضا حتى كذلك في
الخرطوم يعني ونحن ندخل الاسبوع الثالث من
هذه الاشتباكات
وكذلك من من هذا النزاع والصراع العسكري
السوداني السوداني
طيب بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحقيقه يعني
كثير من
المتحدثين يعني
لا مجتمع العربي والدولي يعني عن مجمل 18
ولايه الان 17 ولايه خارج خارج العمليات
العسكريه فقط في غرب دارفور كانت لمده
ثلاث ساعات ثلاثه او اربع عربات من من
رواد الدعم السريعه المتمرده دخلت الى
مدينه
الجنينه والنهج في السوق المركزي
وتضمن الحديث الخرطوم والحديث
المسلحه كيف يستقيم هذا الحديث والقوات
المسلحه تسيطر على كل السودان الان كل هذه
العمليات هي تنحصر في لا يتعدى 13 كيلو
مربع هذا 13 كيلو مربع مستشفى مستشفيات
الاغواط الشعب المسله عند التزام
هل تريدون من القوات المسلحه ان تتصدى
لهذه الشرازمه التي التي تعتمد بالمواطنين
بالمستشفيات في شرق النيل المستشفيات ساعه
مستشفى الخرطوم مستشفى الشعب هل يريدون ان
يستعملوا القوه قوى الضاء القوه الضخمه
لضرب هذه المدن كما حدث في سوريا لضربه
صالح الان مواطن المسله عندها التزام
اخلاقي القوات المسلحه الان الان القتال
فقط في شمال المطار في منطقه منطقه سكنيه
الان القتال في في شرق النيل حول مستشفى
سرجانيل ويعتقد بانه موجود داخل هذا وعدد
كبير من من الجرح جرحهم القوات المسلحه
عند هذا الالتزام الاخلاق الان القوات
المسلحه تمكنت بفضل الله هذا الصباح من
تدمير قوه كبيره جدا كانت غادمه من ليبيا
لدعمها كل المحاولات
المحاولات لدعم المتمردين في شركه في في
في شرق الخرطوم كان بعد الفشل هذا الصباح
تحركت هو من الحدود الليبيه
بليلا وكانت متابعه تم تدميرها في الصحراء
تم تدمير تدمير كامل عربيه ثلاثه ايام على
التوالي كانت هنالك عرضات رباعيه الدعم
تحاول ان تاتي للخرطوم ليلا ولكن انت تفضل
اوقات المسله على الميدان تم تطهير شمال
الخرطوم شمال افريقيا
عند هذه النقطه انت تتحدث عن امدادات
عسكريه دمرها الجيش كانت متجهه من
ليبيا باتجاه
السوداني للخرطوم طبعا مباشره
نريد تفاصيل اوسع اللواء بدر اذا سمحت
المتمرد حفتر متورط تورط تام في هذا العمل
قبل يومين فقط ابنه الصادق حفتر داعي
للخرطوم وكان هنالك اتفاق ما بينهما عندما
يستلف حميد المتمرد السودان يساعدهم في
استلام طرابلس لذلك اغلب القبائل التي
جاءت هذا الحديث
عفوا الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان سعاده
اللواء
قال بانه تواصل مع حفتر واكد له
بالتزامه اتجاه السودان اتجاه هذه الازمه
وبانه لا يدعم طرف على اخر
هذا الرجل لا كلمه له
واغلب في 70% من المقاتلين مقاتلين الان
مع مع المتمردين كانوا يغسلون ما يحسن وهم
غير سودانيين ويحملون
النيجر وفيديوهات كثيره جدا موجوده والان
كثير من الحواري 720 من الموتى في مطار في
مطار مروي 90% منهم غيث سودانيين طيب
سعاده يعني دعني اتحدث معك طيب
التي نقلت له هذا السلاح الى كفره وتحدثنا
فيها معلومات استقبانيه
هذه الطائرات حملت المره الاولى عدد من
الذخائر المضافات حاملين
يتحدث ميدانيا فيما يخص العاصمه الخرطوم
تحدثت قبل قليل بان الدعم السريع يشتبك مع
الجيش في تقريبا مربع ثلاثه عشر كيلو متر
يعني لكن اريد الحديث عن المفاصل الرئيسيه
المناطق الحيويه هنا عن القصر الجمهوري عن
محيط ومبنى القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
كذلك ايضا حتى عن مطار الخرطوم عن جسر حتى
الحلفايه هذا الصباح الحديث عن اشتباكات
دارت حول هذا الجسر وهناك عمليه تمشيط
للجيش السوداني من يسيطر على هذه المواقع
هل حسمت بشكل كامل ام لا تزال هناك
اشتباكات في هذه المناطق المفصليه الهامه
في الخرطوم
طيب قبل ان اوضح هذه المواضيع هنالك اتفاق
منذ 19/4 وزعت فيها تامين الخرطوم اريد ان
اسدد هذه المعلومات
القوات المسلحه ان تؤمن في اللجنه الامنيه
لولايه الخرطوم القوات المسلحه تؤمن
المناطق العسكريه التابعه لها مواد الدعم
السريع تؤمن المواقع الاستراتيجيه
والخدميه من ضمنها
[موسيقى]
كثير من المواقع في الخرطوم عندما قاموا
هذا التمرد هذا التمرد
وا على هذه المواقع الان على اي حديث عن
الهجوم بري من القوات الدعم السريع القوات
الدعم السريع الان لا تستطيع ان تقوم باي
هجوم تم تدمير تدمير كامل اكبر قوه للغات
الدعم السريع موجوده حول مستشفى مستشفى
شرق النيل حوالي 100 سياره لا موجوده وال
قوات المسلحه من الدعم السريع هناك التزام
اخلاقي وديني هناك
وغسل الاسرع الان اي حديث عن الهجوم على
القياده العامه حديث غير صحيح
بعض الرجيمات تضرب من الشرقانين حوالي
عشره كيلو رواد المسلحه او العصر الجمهوري
هو يتحدثون هنالك هنالك
امنه ولا يوجد مسمار حتى مسمار في احدى
حوائط
القياده العامه ولم يطار الخرطوم
مطار الخرطوم توجد بعض مستشفى الساحه يوجد
حول مستشفى الساحه هنالك عربات تابعه
للدعم السريع لماذا لم يتصدى لها ولماذا
لم تضرب جويا لانه هنالك التزام لا يريد
تريد تريد ان يحدث في المواطن السوداني
صفحته للمواطن في سوريا الان
رواد الشعب السوداني مع القوات المسلحه لا
تريد ان تضرب بمغبا بمغبره القوات المسلحه
ان تدمر الاحياء هذه كلها هذه الاحياء لكن
لا نتحمل كشعب السوداني الان ان نرى
الاطفال
ينزعون من داخل هذه المنازل الان 99 وتسعه
من عشره من شعب السوداني موجودين داخل
ولايه الخرطوم لكن الاعلام اعلامهم يصور
العشره الاف 7,000 من السودانيين
الموجودين في الحدود المصريه السودانيه
كانهم الشعب السوداني كله زاحف الى
غير صحيحه
نحن نحن لا نصور في السودان الا بما ينقل
من اخبار من معلومات سواء عبر مراسلي
العربيه الموجودين على الارض او عبر
بيانات ايضا الجيش او حتى ايضا من قبل
قوات الدعم السريع نحن نصور فقط ما يجري
على على الارض بكل موضوعيه ومهنيه اشكرك
جزيلا الشكر من الخرطوم اللواء بدر الدين
حسن عبد الحكم الباحث في اكاديميه الامن
العليا للدراسات الامنيه والاستر
عدد من انصار النظام الرئيسي المعزول عمر
البشير توعدوا بنشر الفوضى في السودان من
اجل قطع الطريق امام اي اتفاق تتاسس
بموجبه حكومه مدنيه التي ستقطع الطريق
امام عودتهم للحكم مجددا قيادات اخوانيه
في نظام البشير شنت حمله تحريض واسعه
لاشعال الحرب وعدم تحقيق انتقال نحو حكومه
مدنيه
على ركام الحرب الجاريه في السودان انصار
الرئيس السابق عمر البشير يبحثون عن موطئ
قدم فالحرب فرصتهم الوحيده وستحدد مصيرهم
انصار البشير وحزب المؤتمر الوطني
الاخواني توعدوا بنشر الفوضى في البلاد
قطعا للطريق امام اي اتفاق تتاسس بموجبه
حكومه مدنيه فالحكومه المدنيه الديمقراطيه
تعني بالاساس عدم عودتهم للحكم مجددا
بعدما قادوا البلاد لمده 30 عاما بقبضه من
حديد
هؤلاء شنوا حمله تحريض واسعه لاشعال الحرب
وما ان اشتعلت حتى ظلوا يطالبون
باستمرارها بل وصل الامر باحد خطبائهم لحد
اصدار فتوى بقتل المدنيين المعارضين
لتواصل الاشتباكات فان بعض الناس لا لا
يكف شره الا بان يقطع دابره وان يقتل لانه
مرض على الخيانه والنفاق خاصه انا اقول
ليس المقاتلين فقط يعني هناك من الاحزاب
العميله من كان ينفخ في نار هذه الحرب
ويهدد بها الحمله استهلها القيادي الحاج
ادم يوسف محرضا انصار حزبه اذ حثهم على
مواجهه القوى المؤيده للحكم المدني
الانتخابات او مداخلات احسن مداخل
كبار وصغار تمشي
في الشارع ما والله كبير ما بقدر امشي
واقع
القيادي في الحركه والوالي السابق الذي
اشتهر بمواقفه المتطرفه انس عمر وصف
الحكومه المدنيه الانتقاليه بالفاشله
كاشفا عن دورهم في اسقاطها ومهددا في
الوقت ذاته باسقاط اي حكومه مدنيه
المره الثانيه
وحنسقطها الرابعه والخامسه ويحكومه
ماذا
اما نائب البشير الاسبق ابراهيم محمود فقد
وجه انصار حزبه بالاستعداد للنزول الى
الميدان في حال توقيع الاتفاق السياسي
النهائي نحن نقول الان استعدوا يا اخواننا
هذا الاتفاق لو اعلم كل الشعب السوداني
لازم يكون في الميدان
انصار حزب المؤتمر الوطني الذي تزعمه
البشير رفعوا شعارا جديدا يقوم على تخوين
كل من ينادي بوقف الحرب حمله الترهيب
والتخوين والتشويه والتخويف هذه تستهدف
قاده القوى المدنيه التي اسقطت نظام
البشير بالثوره الشعبيه في ربيع العام
انصار البشير نشطوا بعيده توقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي اتشنوا حمله تحريض ضخمه ضد هذا
الاتفاق الذي يقضي بتسليم السلطه للمدنيين
التحليلات والوقائع تشير الى ان جماعه
الاخوان وانصار البشير يعتبرون الحرب
الدائره معركتهم الاخيره يلقون فيها بكل
اسلحتهم الامر الذي يجعل سيناريو الحرب
الوحيده المتاحه امام بقائهم فلا خيار اخر
لهم في مواجهه الرفض الشعبي الواسع
لعودتهم الى الحكم من جديد
ما يحدث في السودان ليس حربا
هناك اطراف لعبت دورا في تصعيد المواجهه
وتستفيد من هذه الازمه
من الخرطوم ينضمرون دكتور عبد الناصر سلم
مدير برنامج شرق افريقيا والسودان دكتور
عبد الناصر مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه
ابدا اولا معك من تصريح الخارجيه
السودانيه والتي
ادانت فيه اعتداءات الدعم السريعه على مقر
البعثات والهيئات الدبلوماسيه طالبت ايضا
كذلك المجتمع الدولي بادانه سلوك الدعم
السريع كيف تعلق على هذا البيان
شكرا لكم يا كريم الاستضافه الرحمه
والمغصيه لكل الشهداء الذين سقطوا في هذه
الاحداث الماساويه في السودان انا على ما
اعتقد ان على الطرفين ان يتجنبوا
الصدام في المرافق
الانسانيه من مستشفيات الى الى الى سفارات
الى بيع ساد والى غيرها من المناطق
الحساسه في العاصمه الاشكاليه ان الصراع
يدور في في عاصمه مقتظه
بالمواطنين وهذا ما يقود لحدوث كثير من
الانتهاكات
من استهداف مستشفيات او استهداف مناطق
مدنيه او حتى
القتال داخل الاحياء
المقتظه بالمدنيين هذه قضيه من الممكن ان
نعمل اذا ما تم اذا ما تم اتفاق الاطراف
على وقف اطلاق النار الى ان يعملوا الى ان
يجنبو هذه المواقع
الخدميه عده الاضطرابات او عده القتال في
مراحل اخرى هل نحن امام ازمه في الخرطوم
تحديدا تحولت فيها المستشفيات من مرفق صحي
يقدم الخدمه للمرضى للمصابين ايضا في هذه
الازمه الى سكنات عسكريه كما ذكر الجيش
هو لنكن واقعيين السودان منذ اسبوعين يمر
بازمه سياسيه واجمى انسانيه بصوره كبيره
جدا جدا خروج عدد كبير من المستشفيات من
الخدمه توقف حياه
المواطنين عدم قدره الاطراف الى هذه الى
هذه
الاكله على تثبيت وقت اطلاق النار بصوره
كامله
اسباب من الطبيعه انها سوف تقود في نهايه
المطاف الى حاله من الفوضى الكامل التي لا
تستطيع ان تميز ما بين هل هذا
المبنى عسكري ام مدني هل هذا المبنى طبي
ام انه مبنى عسكري فالامور جميعها قد
الاوراق قد خلطت الساحه السودانيه بصوره
كبيره جدا جدا هذه الامور كما ذكرت انا
سابقا وقف اطلاق النار وتثبيت الهدنه
وتحديد اليه لمراقبه الهدنه ممكن ان يؤدي
الى تهدئه الاوضاع بصوره بصوره كامله هل
هذا ممكن قريبا برايك
انا على ما اعتقد بانه الهدنه كانت طوال
الفترات الماضيه هشه جدا جدا لانه لا توجد
اليه لتطبيق او لمراقبه يا اخي هذه حرب
ولا يمكن ان تكون الهدنه مبنيه على
الطرفين فقط لابد ان تكون هناك اليه
مراقبين على الارض يحدد مواقع سيطره
كل قوه موجوده على الارض
وهم على فتح الممرات الانسانيه لعبور
المواطنين ولعبور الجرحى ولعبور الخدمات
الطبيه والصحيه لتصل للمستفيدين منها يعني
انا لا لا يمكن ان تكون هناك
هنا مبنيه على النوايا الحسنه ما بين الاط
راف وفي نهايه المطر لا توجد فيها نوايا
حسنه يوجد فيها الزام للاطراف الموجوده
المجتمع الدولي للاسف لا يريد ان يناقش
هذه النقطه بسبب بسيط جدا جدا وجود
مراقبين على ارض الواقع يعتمد على ان
الامم المتحده يجب عليها ان تتدخل في هذا
الملف وهذا سوف يقود الى تدوير
القضيه بصوره او باخرى ممكن ان ان ان
يستعين المجتمع الدولي بمجموعات من
الايكات لمراقبه وقت اطلاق النار الان
الهدنه الاخيره
سلامتهم على الارض
الو من سيضمن مراقبتهم على يعني من سيضمن
سلامه هؤلاء المراقبين على الارض اذا كانت
البعثات الدبلوماسيه الهيئات الدبلوماسيه
تعرضت
لهجمات تم استهداف ايضا بعض اعضاء هذه
القنصليات او السفارات في الخرطوم المصريه
والفرنسيه كذلك الامريكيه ايضا التي قتل
من بعثتها
شخصين كذلك يطرح هذا السؤال الان من سيضمن
سلامه المراقبين الدوليين في السودان
من
الاشياء
الامريكيه هي تحديد اليه لمراقبه وقت
اطلاق النار بوجود الطرفين يعني الدعم
السريع والجيش يكون لهم ممثلين في هذه
الاليه المراقبه
اطلاق هذه الاطراف ممكن ان تلتزم لانها لا
اعتقد انه اي طرف في ساحه سياسيه سودانيه
يريد ان يدخل في اشكاليه مع المجتمع
الدولي اكثر من الازمه اصلا موجوده اليوم
او بالاعتداء على مراقبين لوليين جاءوا
لبسط او لمراقبه وقت اطلاقا معك هذه
الاليه اذا ما تم الاتفاق عليها ممكن ان
تكون مرحله اولى من مراحل تثبيت الغنه انا
لا اقول هدنه كامله ولكن
تنسب كبيره جدا جدا على على ارض الواقع
على ارض الواقع بعدها ممكن ان يذهب الناس
الى هدنه ممكن ان تكون كامله لكن هذه
الهدن السابقه والهدنه التي سوف تاتي
لاحقا ان صح التعبير من دون
وطقتها سوف تقوم مثل مثل الخمسه هدن
السابقه التي ما زال صوت الحرب والاقتتال
ما زال مستمره فيها اشكرك جزيل الشكر من
الخرطوم الدكتور عبد الناصر سلم مدير
برنامج شرق افريقيا والسودان
وفي متابعه لجهود السعوديه في عمليات
الاجلاء من السودان افاد مراسل العربيه
بان طائره سعوديه اجلت 82 شخصا بينهم 45
سعوديا من بورتسودان الى ميناء جده
[موسيقى]
وينها
تستمر عمليات النزوح للسودانيين الفارينه
من الاشتباكات الى الحدود المصريه
السودانيه وبينما تقلص اعداد القادمين الى
معبر اركين زادت نسبه الوافدين عبر منفذ
قسط ومنه تمر الحافلات الواصله عبر عباره
نيليه نحو مدينه ابو سمبل
[موسيقى]
هكذا تبدو بوابه الخروج من معبر ارجين
تقلص كبير في اعداد القادمين من السودان
وتقلص ايضا في اعداد الحافلات التي
تنتظرهم منذ اكثر من اسبوعين
[موسيقى]
حولهم بقى على المعبر الثاني اللي هو
النهر ده بس
كلها على هناك النهارده الحركه خفيفه ايام
قد تكون الحركه منقصه طبعا من الجانب
الاشتباكات بس احنا ما نعرفش اي حاجه ايه
اللي حاصل في الجانب السوداني
اصحابه سيارات نقل البضائع الكبيره
سينجحون اخيرا في المرور من معبر ارجين
والدخول الى الاراضي السودانيه بعد توقف
دام اكثر من اسبوعين
[موسيقى]
نحن الان داخل احد الحافلات التي خرجت
اخيرا من معبر ارجينا من يستقلون هذه
الحافله يشعرون بالارهاق وتحدثوا معنا على
معلومه من خلال هذه الرحله الطويله لكل
الناس تتجه لحالفه فاحنا كنا اخر بس جاي
على ارجينا
المعبر زحمه شديده في غريب 30 باص والمعبر
زحمه شديد لكنها نحن شنو
خشينا بس عملنا الاجراءات ولقينا خلينا
على بعض مصريه جابتنا جابتنا
[موسيقى]
وسواء بري او مينائي ابو سمبل النيلي فان
الرحله تكتمل اخيرا بالوصول الى الحدود
المصريه احمد عثمان
لقناتي العربيه والحدث من ميناء ابو سمبل
النيلي
ومن مدينه بورتسودان ينضم الينا مراسل
عربيه نزار البقدونس مرحبا بك معي في هذه
الساعه على شاشه العربيه نريد ان تقول لنا
الصوره اليوم من بورسودان عمليات الاجل
ايضا ايضا كذلك كيف تجري
هذا هو اليوم التاسع لعمليات اجلاء
الراغبين في مغادره السودان بعد المواجهات
المسلحه التي بدات قبل اكثر من اسبوعين في
الخرطوم وعدد من مدن السودان عمليه
الاجلاء متواصله هذه العمليه التي بدات
عبر طريق البحر هنا من خلفه في ميناء
بورسودان في الحادي والعشرين من ابريل
وبدات عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي في الثالث
والعشرين من هذا الشهر عمليات الاجلاء
مستمره بتنسيق واشراف من قبل القوات
المسلحه السودانيه التي تنسق هنا مع
الشرطه وتنسق ايضا مع هيئه الموانئ
البحريه وتنسق مع عديد الواجهات والوحدات
الفنيه والاداريه والعسكريه والامنيه وحتى
المجتمعيه لسلامه وسلاسه ونجاح هذه
العمليه الكبرى لاجلاء الاف الرعايه خلال
الساعات الماضيه منذ صباح هذا اليوم عبر
مطار بورسودان الدولي
غادرت اكثر من خمس طائرات في طريقها الى
المملكه العربيه السعوديه والى دوله
الامارات قبل نصف ساعه من الان غادرت
طائره على متنها
128 من رعايه عدد من الدول الاوروبيه
والعربيه ومن بينهم رعايا لدوله الامارات
خمس طائرات ايضا غادر الصباح هذا اليوم
اكثر من سته الاف ونحو
7000 يمكن ان نؤكد بانهم غادروا خلال
الايام الماضيه عبر مطار بورسودان الدولي
واكثر من 8000 وقد يستمر هذا العدد في
الارتفاع غادروا عبر هذا الميناء من خلف
ميناء بورتسودان الصوره ستوضح اكثر بعد
قليل علمنا بان سفينه امريكيه ستصل هنا
الى المرسى الرئيس في مدينه بورسودان
لتقيل عدد من رعايه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ايضا هنالك
سفينه سعوديه ستصل بعد قليل لتحيط الرحال
هنا في ميناء بورسودان الذي يشهد حركه
دؤوبه
منذ الحادي والعشرين من هذا الشهر وتستمر
الرحلات وما زالت مستمره لاجلاء رعايه
عديده الدول اكثر من السبعين دوله اجلت
رعاياها عبر ميناء بورسودان الدولي وعبر
مطار بورسودان الدولي وما زالت هذه
العمليه مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
السؤال ايضا كذلك عن
السفن ايضا التي
ستجلي بعض الرعايه الموجودين والمواطنين
الموجودين في
بورت سودان هذا اليوم هل من معلومات ايضا
اضافيه بخلاف طبعا السفينه السعوديه التي
ستصل خلال الساعات القادمه الى بورتسودان
نعم يعني المعلومات عن السفينه بريطانيه
ليس مؤكد حتى الان هل اخذت الاذن ام ليس
بعد السفينه الامريكيه يبدو انها على وصول
هنالك ايضا سفينه السعوديه على وصول
لاجلاء ايضا مئات من رعايه الدول
الاوروبيه والعربيه الذين
يوجدون هنا في مدينه بورسودان اكثر من
اسبوع ونصف عدد من رعايه الدول الاوروبيه
والعربيه والافريقيه ما زالوا هنا في
مدينه بورسودان يعملون على توفيق اوضاعهم
يعملون على تنسيق عمليه السفر مع سفارتهم
ومع سفاره المملكه العربيه السعوديه التي
تنسق مع مختلف الدول العالم عبر ممثليها
وعبر بعثاتها الدبلوماسيه وعبر سفاراتها
في الخرطوم لتنسيق عمليه اجلار عايد دول
الاوروبيه ما يؤكد عليه بان ميناء
بورسودان يوميا يستقبل ما بين ثلاث الى
اربع الى خمس رحلات لسفن وقطع بحريه
عسكريه تصل تباعا الى ميناء بورسودان
وتتواصل اعداد هذه السفن لا يمكن الجزم
بنسبه عددها لان الطلبات والبرقيات
والاذونات تاتي باستمرار الى ميناء
لاجلاء الرعايه ما ان يتم التنسيق وما ان
يتم التوافق مع عدد المغادرين والترتيبات
مع القوات المسلحه ومع الشرطه ومع هيئه
الموانئ مباشره تاخذ السفن والقطعه
البحريه الاذن لتدخل الى ميناء بورسودان
وبعدها تتم عبريه عمليه الاجلاء عبر سفن
صغيره كما تشاهدون عبر هذا الطقه هنا في
ميناء بورسودان الذي يعمل على نقل الركاب
والنقل الرعايه الدول من الميناء الى
مناطق قريبه من الميناء التي تتمركز فيها
السفن البحريه وبعدها تبدا عمليه الاجلاء
من ميناء بورسودان الى ميناء جده الى
مختلف الموالي في المنطقه العربيه ذكرت
قبل قليل يعني بان السفن تحتاج الى اخذ
الاذن وربما ايضا حتى ذلك يسري على
القاعده العسكريه التي ينطلق منها
الطيران الذي يصل الى الى بورتسودان اريد
ان اسال هنا عن الاجراءات عن التنسيق كيف
يتم بين السلطات السودانيه وبين السفن
التي يعني تود ان تجري رعاياها او
مواطنيها او اي ضاح حتى راعيه بعض دول
الصديقه نزار
يعني هذه العمليه منذ ان بدات قبل تسعه
ايام ارتات الجهات المعنيه هنا في بورت
سودان وحتى في العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
في القياده العامه بان هنالك عمليه اجلاء
ستتم لان مختلف رعايه الدول الاوروبيه
والبعثات طلبت السلطات في السودان بان
تتيح لها عمليه الاجلاء وان تيسر هذه
العمليه وهذا ما التزم به الجيش السوداني
القوات المسلحه في بيانه قبل ايام بانه
سيعمل على تسهيل وتمهيد عمليه الاجلاء لكل
الراغبين من البعثات والمؤسسات
الدبلوماسيه ورعايا الدول وموظفي الامم
المتحده الذين يعملون في السودان بعدها
مباشره هنا في شرق السودان تم تشكيل
لجنتين لجنه لاجلاء الرعايه عبر البحر
برئاسه
ضابط رفيع في القوات المسلحه برتبه لواء
بحري وتم تشكيل ايضا لجنه لعمليه الاجلاء
عبر
برعايه واشراف ايضا ضابط رفيع في القوات
المسلحه هذه هذه اللجان واللجنتان يعملان
على التنسيق مع البعثات الدبلوماسيه
يستلمون اول باول كل الطلبات كل الاسماء
يعملون على حصر الدبلوماسيين ورعاي الدول
الاوروبيه بتنسيق مع هيئه الجوازات هنا في
وزاره الداخليه هذه العمليه تتم تحت اشراف
وتحت مراقبه الجيش والشرطه والجهات
الامنيه كل دوله ترغب في ادلاء رعاياها
عليها ان تنسق مع اللجنتين المعنيتين بهذه
العمليه وبعدها مباشره تمضي الاجراءات وفق
جدول زمني يحدد مكان اقامه الرعايه ويحدد
التوقيت الزماني لوصول الباخره او الطائره
وبعدها يجلى مباشره للرعايه سواء كان عبر
البحر او عبر الميناء في عمليه يبدو حتى
اللحظه بانها تمضي بسلاسه وتمضي بيسر مع
كثافه الاعداد التي تصل الى ميناء
بورسودان الجيش يؤكد بانه سيمضي في هذه
العمليه يؤكد بانه على قدر التحدي في ان
جاء عمليه الاجلاء وانه مستعد لاستقبال كل
الطلبات التي تصل اليه وتصل الى شرق
السودان الاجلاء رعايه دول الاوروبيه
والعربيه وحتى السودانيين المقيمين في عدد
من الدول تقدموا بطلباتهم لاجلائهم من
السودان اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه
المعلومات والتفاصيل الارقام كذلك التي
نقلتها لنا من بورتسودان مراسل العربيه
نزار
في متابعه للاوضاع الطبيه اكد المسؤوله
الاعلامي للهلال الاحمر السوداني للعربيه
ان العمل داخل المستشفيات يجري بامكانيات
محدوده جدا وان هناك حاجه ماسه لوصول
المساعدات من الخارج لتجاوز الاوضاع التي
باتت مترديه
شهاده الدبه يعني الوضع الذاتي وببعض
المساعدات من بعض الجهات حتى المنظمات
القاسمه بما موجود عندها من مخزون ثابت
ومنظم المنظمات بما فيها حتى الهلال
الاحمر السوداني وغيرها كل المنظمات
المعنيه بمساعده المساعدات الانسانيه
وبتعمل في القطاع الصحي في وضع طبيعي
كجانب جوانب العمل الانساني مخزون طبيعي
لكن مخزون الحالات العاديه للحالات
الطارئه في الوضع العادي يعني فدلوقتي
بتدبر اضافه الى
مساهمات
الاطباء بتشكيلاتهم المختلفه بهيئات
بنقابات
بتنظيمهم الحالي لمجابهه الواقع
من ومن الخاص وكذا لكن عشان نسبه نجابه
موجوده دي لازم تيجي مساعدات من الخارج
[موسيقى]
يه
الخلاصه عندنا تماما او على وشك يا ادويه
الضغط
[موسيقى]
وجدت الاحداث الدواء حقك تنسالين
مخلوط ومعاوى الحقن ولدها يفتش وما خلوا
اي حته فتش عشان تقول
[موسيقى]
واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام هذا الفيديو
المتداول فيديو متداول اذا
لتخريب منزل
رئيس حزب الامه السوداني كما نشاهد طبعا
في هذا الفيديو ذكر بان قوات الدعم السريع
هي من اقتحمت هذا
المنزل منزل رئيس حزب الامه مبارك الفاضل
بالخرطوم اذا هذه صور
متداوله فيديو ايضا كذلك لمنزل رئيس حزب
الامه السوداني مبارك الفاضل بالخرطوم بعد
ان تم اقتحامه من قبل قوات الدعم السريع
كما نشاهد في الصوره الان عمليات تخريب
اذن
وربما يعني عمليات
نهب كما نشاهد امامنا في الصوره لمنزل
[موسيقى]
هو من اتهم طبعا قوات الدعم السريع بانها
هي منهاجمت منزله في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم واقتحمته
طبعا هذه الصور وهذا الفيديو الذي ذكرنا
بانه متداول الان لمنزل السياسيه السوداني
مبارك الفاضل اتهم فيه قوات الدعم السريع
بانها هي من اقتحمت هذا
المنزل وقامت بتخريبه كما نشاهد امامنا
على الشاشه ايضا وعلى وقع استمرار
الاشتباكات وغياب اي بوادر لحل قريب وصف
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي الوضع الانسانيه
في السودان بالكارثي
شوارع الخرطوم شبه خاليه لا امن ولا امان
اما اسواقها يكبل الكساد ايدي التجار فيها
فالمعروض قليل والطلب شبه معدوم
قالت
ان شاء الله اقرب الاحداث دي شوارع
ب 30,000
اقتصاد السودان صعد على سكه خسائر لا يمكن
التصور ابعادها وبات شبح المجاعه يهدد كل
من تقطعت بهم سبل الخروج منه برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي وصف الوضع الانساني في
البلاد بالكارثي مؤكدا انه يجب ان يتوقف
القتال اولا لتمكين ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه بامان
وضع انساني يزداد كل يوم سوءا وتحيط به
مخاوف من ارتفاع جنني في اسعار المواد
الغذائيه والوقود معنى فادي الاموال
والامدادات الاساسيه وتعطل الانظمه
المصرفيه
حالهم بات غايه في السوء والتردي واصعب
مهامهم تامين قوتهم اليومي وحاجاتهم
الغذائيه حيث شهدت اسعار السلع
الاستهلاكيه الضروريه في العاصمه الخرطوم
ارتفاعا كبيرا ومفاجئا مع اعتبره
السودانيون غير مبرر في حين عزاه البعض
الى استغلال التجار لظروف المواطنين
الصعبه
اندلاع الحرب جدد المخاوف من انزلاق
الاقتصاد السوداني نحو الانهيار الشامل
فمع دخول الحرب الاسبوع الثالث واستمرار
عمليات الاجلاء سترتفع احتمالات اصابه
النشاط الاقتصادي بالشلل وستنجر البلاد
نحو مصير مظلم واكبر خطرا
اياد حمود العربيه
[موسيقى]
والان الى جوله لابرز الاخبار الدوليه حيث
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
قوات موسكو وقصفت موقع القياده والمراقبه
للطائرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه قرب منطقه
خرسون والحقت وحدات المدفعيه اضرارا
بنيرانها بموقع القياده والمراقبه ومركز
التحكم للطائرات دون الطيار التابع لقوات
الدفاع الاقليميه الاوكرانيه مضيفا ان قوه
موسكو دمرت مستودعه تخزين الذخيره
والمعدات قرب المدينه الساحليه جنوب
البلاد واضحا ان القصف الروسيه اسفر عن
مقتل 30 شخصا من صفوف القوات الاوكرانيه
وتدمير اكثر من عشر مركبات قتاليه مسطحه
كشفت شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه عن معلومات
وفقا لصور التقطتها الاقمار الصناعيه
ماكسار ان روسيا انشات خنادق دفاعيه تمتد
من القرم وحد دونتس تحسبا للهجوم المضاد
الذي ستطلقه اوكرانيا في اي لحظه مشيره
الى ان روسيا عمل طيله الاشهر السته
الماضيه على بناء مجموعه معقده من
الدفاعات التي يصعب اختراقها حيث تتركز
خنادق روسيا بشكل اقرب قرب الخطوط
الاماميه في الشرق وتمتد من زبروجيا الى
القرم
من جهته قال المتحدث باسم القوات
الاوكرانيه
شرفه ان بلاده لا تزال تسيطر على طريق
امداد هام مؤد الى بخموت مؤكده لوسائل
اعلان محليه ان الوضع في باخموت لا يزال
صعبا بسبب محاولات القوات الروسيه السيطره
على طريق الحياه المؤدي للمدينه الا ان
قوات بلاده لن تسمح للروس بقطع الخدمات
اللوجستيه للجيش الاوكراني
تعتزم كوريا الشماليه تعزيز الردع العسكري
ضد كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده
منتقده اتفاق القمه الذي عقد هذا الاسبوع
بين البلدين بشان تعزيز الردع الموسع
الامريكي ووصفته بانه نتائج سياسه عدائيه
شائنه ضد بيونجي كانت واشنطن مشاهدين قد
وافقت على نشر غواصات المسلحه نويا في
كوريا الجنوبيه واشراك سول في التخطيط
النووي لمواجهه التهديدات النوويه
حذر الاطباء اطفال من دول اوروبيه من نقص
ادويه الاطفال بما فيها المضادات الحيويه
وعلاجات الربو في اوروبا وقال الاطباء في
رساله موجهه الى وزراء الصحه انه من
الضروري ايجاد حل سريع للمشكلات التي
تواجهها مخزونات الادويه في اوروبا مشيرين
الى انه من مسؤوليه صناع القرار السياسي
ضمان الانتاج والامداد الكافيين للتاكد من
توافر الادويه الاساسيه لرعايه الاطفال
اعلن رجل الاعمال الملياردير ايلون ماسك
عن خطه لمنصه تويتر تسمح لناشري الوسائل
الاعلاميه بتقاضي بدل من المستخدمين على
اساس قراءه كل مقاله على حده وبنقره واحده
وقال ماسك ان الخطه ستمكن المستخدمين
الذين لم يشتركوا شهريا بدفع بدل اعلى
مقابل قراءه كل ما قال بشكل عابر وان
الامر سيشكل مكسبا رئيسيا للمؤسسات
الاعلاميه والجمهور
ضرب اعصار قوي ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه
بحسب ما اعلنت هيئه الارصاد الجويه
الوطنيه في البلاد وادى الطقس القاسي الى
قلب السيارات وتحطيم النوافذ والاشجار
واوضحت السلطات انه لم يتم الابلاغ عن
وقوع اي اصابات لكنها طلبت من السكان الحد
من نشاطهم الخارجي والابتعاد عن خطوط
الكهرباء المتساقطه خاصه مع توقعات ترجح
ان اعصارا او اثنين سيتبعان هذه العاصفه
ازلنا نتابع واياكم مشاهدينا الكرام هذه
الصور
المباشره من العاصمه
السودانيه
الخرطوم كما نشاهد الان على شاشه العربيه
اشتباكات متقطعه اذا منذ صباح اليوم بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في اخر
ايام الهدنه التي تعيشها السودان الهدنه
التي كانت قد توسطت فيها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
نهايه هذه الساعه الاخباريه مشاهدينا التي
خصصنا معظمها للحديث عن الشان
السوداني انتهت الان نعود الى استكمال
التغطيه او في بدايه الساعه القادمه تغطيه
الشان السوداني مع الزميله نادين خماش
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه
والوخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات